a career ceiling is when you get stuck
and it can happen a couple different
ways it can be the 70% of Americans who
according to Gallup don't like their
jobs but don't do anything about it
they've just kind of accepted that a job
is just a job and this is what I do for
the rest of my life we eat at TGI
Fridays not TGI mondays for a reason on
the office was a popular show for a
reason
Gilbert books sold a lot for a reason
because we get stuck for me that was
climbing to the top of a career ladder
and maybe that's something you relate to
I was 32 years old
and I worked at Auto Trader and I had a
great job but I was a senior content
designer and there was no SuperDuper
senior content designer position above
that I had come to the end of that
ladder and a32 that was overwhelming to
think okay my career Ball has already
stopped rolling and this is where I am
companies get stuck - they hit ceilings
I read a great article in New York Times
that asked why didn't Kodak create
Instagram
why didn't Polaroid create Instagram of
all the people that should have
understood our love affair with
photography why did they miss it and
what happens for a company is that you
start with innovation and risk but then
when things go well you tend to move
from innovation mode to protection mode
and you start to protect the things
you've already built so nobody could
walk into Kodak and say I have an idea
for an app and it won't make any money
but at the end of two years it'll be
worth a billion dollars
so they got stuck and industries get
stuffed - I spoke to a group of
orthodontists and to be an amazing
orthodontist right now you have to be
good at social media email marketing and
running a business do you know what they
don't teach at orthodontic school social
media email marketing and running a
business so they have a choice to get
unstuck and the key when you hit a
career ceiling is to work on your skills
it's impossible to get stuck somewhere
old if you keep learning something new
and that's the concept of a ceiling what
are some signs you've hit a career
ceiling the sense of just repetition
over and over again you know you've hit
a ceiling when you feel Monday on Sunday
when it's Sunday at noon and you could
already feel Monday that Monday is
creeping into your weekend and you know
you've hit a ceiling where you have a
career that owns your weekdays and
haunts your weekends and you see that
happen a lot where pee
can't even really enjoy vacation if
you've ever had that feeling where you
go on a week-long vacation and right at
the last day you finally have that sense
of okay I can do this and the next day
your vacation is over and you go back to
work and you stand wistfully in the
break room and kind of look out the
window with a said cup of coffee and
think I was free once and it was
yesterday you know when you've hit a
ceiling or you're not growing you're not
being challenged at work that there's a
large part of you that's not getting to
enter the building
if you've got say ten different skills
ten things you're good at and you get to
do one of them at work and ninety
percent of you the best parts of you
have to get left at home then there's a
chance you're in a ceiling the other way
you know is if your industry starts
leaving you behind
if you're a graphic designer for
instance I mean a lot of graphic
designers and they tell me John I
remember in college there was a time
where I could take an online design
class for fun as an elective and then
one day I woke up and if I didn't know
how to design for the Internet I was a
dinosaur and the industry had changed
and so a lot of times you know you've
hit a ceiling when your industry is
changing and there's new technologies or
new things you need to know how to do
and you're not learning those and you're
trying to protect the old way and
meanwhile the industry is going these
are the things that matter these are the
new currencies those are signs that
you've hit a ceiling the most important
thing you can do in a ceiling when you
hit one is to start to develop your
skills skills are the hammer that helps
you break through a ceiling it's not
your attitude I used to think that maybe
if I just developed a bad enough
attitude and slammed my head into the
ceiling long enough and hard enough that
would fix things but no it's it's skills
you need most because when you do
something positive when you have a
positive experience in your life say
you're gonna start a blog or move to a
new city or kind of jump out there I
like to talk about jump moments a lot
that feels great on day one every other
day after that is you working on your
skills if you've ever started a blog the
first day is amazing you get a URL you
get Google Analytics you go somebody in
Copenhagen is reading my blog it's
amazing and every other day after that
is you working on it and developing the
content and developing the skill so when
you hit a ceiling it doesn't have to be
a bad thing and actually be a laboratory
for you to get better it can actually be
the gym hitting a ceiling is leg day
nobody likes leg day but it's your
chance to separate yourself from all the
other people that aren't going
to put in the work that aren't going to
develop the new skills I think about an
industrial designer my friend worked
with and he hit a ceiling moment he was
amazing at sketching things by hand
amazing at it but his company said we
need you to learn AutoCAD AutoCAD is
where we're headed and for a while he
fought it and said I'm faster I can
write these amazing sketches with him
but eventually he lost that and he lost
his job and so when you hit a ceiling
you have a choice you can you can change
it you can work on your skills or you
can stay stuck and eventually lose your
position lose your relevancy and I've
hit a ceiling right now myself I write
books and I speak a lot and I do a lot
with social media and I asked a roomful
of high schoolers as a blogger who here
reads blogs nobody raised their hand I
thought good good to know and I said
well what mediums do they use and they
all said they're on snapchat and they
all mention these things and I'm just
not part of right now so I have a choice
if I want to stay relevant to the next
generation if I want to be able to speak
about career and which is something that
starts as young as high school I might
need to be on snapchat I might need to
look at different technologies and go be
part of that conversation so when you
bump into a ceiling that's where you
stand we develop the skill to get past
this ceiling or will you stay stuff
you